bonjour je suis charline van ackere pour
brut
[Musique]
pas cette question non des proches il a
plié le guen ya quoi il ya 30 ans sur
cette question un genre drop de
questions y a plus rien à dire
et pourtant nous la pause toujours donc
c'est que ça veut dire quelque chose
c'est que malgré à l'art c'est mal c'est
une question on a la réponse
on a même la réponse de la part du gars
qui est le mieux positionné en france et
dans la francophonie pour y répondre et
on l'a repose peut remettre en question
copernic aussi c'est c'est très bien il
faut remettre en question les évidences
moi je suis pour donc c'est vrai je
réponds quand même peut-on rire de tout
ben oui pas avec tout le monde comme
disait desproges bien sûr est-ce que
vous avez déjà été censuré est ce que
quelqu'un au niveau texte quelqu'un
relis mes textes moi même sinon voilà
fin du débat qu'est-ce que l'humour
belge
alors ça mon vieux qu'est ce que l'amour
beige mais déjà - la belgique je sais
pas ce que c'est et je pense qu'aucun
belge ne sait ce que c'est que la
belgique donc l'humour belge
s'il faut donner un passeport à l'humour
je suis incapable de répondre est ce
qu'il ya un humour suisse est ce qu'il
ya un humour québécois est ce qu'il ya
un humour limougeaud est ce qu'il ya un
humour breton un humour corse il ya peu
non tim premier degré je plaisante
est ce qu'il ya un humour belge
alors j'essaie de répondre
d'intellectualité la chose et je réponds
souvent qu'on a on est dans une
monarchie on a un roi une reine dont on
se fout allègrement de la tronche donc
sans doute on est moins on a appris à
pas du tout être qu'on se défendant avec
les ors du pouvoir étant donné que la
l'elysée ressemblent souvent depuis des
lustres à une monarchie
peut-être plus en classe en moquer avec
décontraction mais je suis pas sûr qu'il
ya tellement de différence avec l'humour
français à ce niveau là
[Musique]
la politique française est devenue
tellement drôle et caricaturale que
selma fait glisser vers l'humour j'ai
pas fait exprès moi j'aimais bien d'être
journaliste alors après sur tout ce qui
est instagram twitter ce genre de choses
là je déconne je suis maurice tu pas du
tout journaliste mais à la radio il ya
un fond encore un vieux fond de
techniques journalistiques appliqué à
mon travail
dans un premier temps mais le résultat
qui est à l'antenne ne l'est pas je
prétends pas du tout c'est pas un édito
non plus je prétends pas il ya des gens
qui font ça très très bien il ya des
gens qui sont très drôles en faisant des
éditos par exemple à christophe barbier
ses éditos mois jean lou pin et sont
très très drôle
et quand il fait le plein le poirier
alors là c'est à lui qu'il faut poser la
question
un christophe quand tu fais le poirier
alors un journaliste ou un saltimbanque
ou un cirque du soleil s'ouvre à toi mon
gars
pensez-y
[Musique]
alors si vous posez cette question c'est
que macro et de droite cqfd
parce que en tant que président de la
république
évidemment c'est lui qu'on attaque le
plus comme il a explosé tout ce qu'il ya
autour
il est au centre et nous en tant que
bouchons évidemment on s'attaque au
pouvoir donc évidemment c'est emmanuel
macron qui en prend le plus avec son
gouvernement
mais je pense que si on regarde bien le
panel des chroniques bon il faut dire
que la droite est particulièrement drôle
c'est sur la gauche et particulièrement
affligeante donc c'est toujours plus
facile de travailler avec les ceux qui
sont marrants ceux qui sont affligeants
c'est un autre exercice plus la droite
sera présente dans dans l'actualité
c'est toujours à celui qui fait plus de
conneries que j'ai pas qu'elle déduction
peut en tirer